so with the ant-man trailer expected to
arrive in theaters in the next few weeks
or so we're gonna do a video discussing
the character but what we're gonna do is
we're gonna focus on Scott Lang in this
video now the reason why is because
Scott Lang is going to be the version of
ant-man that we're gonna see in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we'll see Hank
Pym but Hank Pym will be playing the
role of ant-man and so it makes sense
that we would focus on a Scott Lang with
regards to this character discussion now
initially Scott Lang had first appeared
in Marvel Comics in the Avengers issue
number 181 but the problem here is that
this initial appearance isn't given any
context he's simply a character that
just appears when we see the Cyclops and
beast arrived at Avengers mansion and
are immediately attacked by some sort of
metallic tentacles that as they
explained had the same kind of physical
strength as Thor but once they arrived
inside they see someone who is
effectively tampering around inside of
the building and they immediately attack
but they're told to stop by Tony Stark
who explains to them that this person is
Scott Lang and that this person is
working on Tony Stark's security system
now in order to understand how it is we
got to this place with Scott Lang we
have to jump back to his I guess
chronological first appearance or in
terms of his historical appearance in
Marvel Comics with Marvel premiere issue
number 47 and 1979 and what this does is
it gives a Scott Lang in relation to his
character evolution in relation to how
it was that he became an employee of
Tony Stark
and what we learn in this story is that
Scott Lang was previously in prison he
had been serving a five-year stent for
for armed robbery or for robbery and and
some degree then what we see here is
that Scott Lang is being released from
prison on on good behavior now the
relationship between himself and the
warden isn't necessarily we take
something we'd expect to see in any real
world kind of scenario they seem to be
on very good terms and in fact the
warden says he recognizes the good
behaviors of Scott Lang has been
demonstrating and that because of this
he set up an interview with stark
international for Scott Lang and so what
happens is Scott Lang undergoes the
process
working for Tony Stark and he's very
adept at what it is that he does because
he's a genius with electronics he
impresses 20 start with his knowledge
but the problem here for Scott Lang is
that while all this is taking place his
daughter Cassandra Lang has biggg
diagnosed with a heart condition and
this heart condition will most likely
kill her there was something going on in
her heart where by one of her valves is
being blocked by a very thin membrane
and this membrane is keeping the
appropriate flow of blood from going
where it needs to go which of course
will end up in her death and so what
Scott Lang begins to do is to ponder the
idea of going back to crime because of
the fact that regardless of the kind of
pay raises that he's getting from stark
international the fact remains that he's
simply not able to pay the medical bills
here and so what he does is he begins
going about the process of canvassing
different houses of looking at different
houses with which he can later on break
into one of these houses of course
belonging to Hank him now before he
actually turns to a life of crime
he is informed that there is a woman
named dr. Sondheim and this woman has
basically created a process whereby she
can surgically go through and eliminate
this blockage in the heart of Cassandra
lang thereby cheering her of her ailment
and so what uh what Scott Lane does is
he goes to meet with dr. Sondheim but as
soon as he does she is kidnapped and he
is overpowered by a group from cross
technological enterprises now we don't
really know what the purpose is behind
why it is she's kidnapped but for Scott
Lane the idea here of him being you want
to speed with her of him being able to
perhaps persuade her to maybe take on
the task of helping Scott Lang's
daughter without any sort of charge is
basically beyond his capabilities at
this point there's really nothing he can
do to try to rescue her and so what he
does here is he basically decides to
take the road to commit crime he decides
to go back to square one again then what
he does is he goes back to Hank PEM's
house after it being one of the houses
that he had canvassed and when he breaks
into the house he realizes that this is
that this house does belong to Hank for
him suddenly he was previously unaware
of but he also comes across hank pens
armoire his ant-man armor now by this
point Hank Pym has abandoned the role of
ant-man and has taken on the role of
Yellow Jacket and so that's the reason
why this armor sits unused
in a cabinet and so what Scott Lang
realizes is that he can take this armor
and he can play the role of a superhero
and he can rescue dr. Sondheim and by
rescuing her he can put this armor back
or perhaps turn himself in no harm no
foul and he can basically avoid the role
of being a criminal and having to go
back to prison again and so what he does
is he donned the armor and he begins
experimenting with it he begins seeing
whether or not it can work the way that
it's supposed to if he can actually
control the armor which of course he's
successful in doing and so what we do is
we switch to Marvel premiere issue
number 48 and with issue number 48 we
see that as Hank Pym we're I'm sorry as
a Scott Lang is breaking into cross
technological enterprises he comes
across Darrin cross now Darrin cross is
in the middle of a surgery and what he
explains to Scott Lang is that the
reason behind why the why dr. Sondheim
was kidnapped was because Darren cross
had the same heart ailment as Cassandra
Lange as Scott Lang's daughter and so
his intention here was to kidnap dr.
Sondheim and force dr. Sondheim to
perform surgery on him to eliminate this
this against this membrane along the
valves of his hard that would in turn
cure him and so what happens the Scott
Lang tries to fight Darren cross but
he's immediately overpowered and Darren
cross throws him in prison those woman's
so and so but Scott Lang does is he
takes out some of some of these antennae
that he had and that he had hidden away
and he uses the antenna to call for
backup from other ants as well as a
shrinking down to his ant form and what
happens is that when guards arrive to
either check on him or remove him from
his cell he grows back into his normal
form immediately overpowers the guards
and goes back along the process of
attacking Darren cross once more and
what happens over the course of the
conflict between both dare to cross and
Scott Lang is that while they're
fighting Darren cross effectively kills
over he simply just dies and so what
happens here is dr. Sondheim informed us
that when Scott Lang had initially
interrupted the surgery that dr.
Sondheim had taken the time while
everyone was distracted and Darren cross
was unconscious to read I guess to
reinstall Darren Darren crosses old
heart and so when Scott Lang and Darren
cross were
fighting one another daring crosses
heart gave out and Darren cross ended up
dying here and so what happens as we
progress towards the end of this story
is that Scott Lang eventually is
travelling back ride yesterday's travel
back to the hospital with dr. Sondheim
and he encounters Hank him and then his
initial intention here is to confess to
tell hank pym what it is that he's done
which he does do but what hank pym tells
us Scott Lang is that when Scott Lang
had first arrived at Hank chat Hank
PEM's house and taken his armor that
Hank Pym was watching him the entire
time albeit in his in a smaller form and
that Hank Pym had followed Scott Lang to
see why it was that he had stolen his
armor and while Hank Pym had initially
been subdued by the security systems at
at cross technological enterprises that
he was aware enough to see what it was
that Scott Lang was doing and why it was
he had taken the armour of ant-man and
so what Hank Pym tell Scott Lang is to
keep the armor that he can take on the
role and maintain the role of ant-man
but only as long as he does it for the
greater good
and so what we see over the course of
Marvel Comics in relation to Scott Lang
is that he plays a multitude of
different roles under the role of
ant-man of course he is part of the
Avengers for quite some time but he also
fights alongside Alpha Flight and he
fights alongside the Fantastic Four now
ultimately the role of Hank Pym comes to
an end when he is presumably killed
during the Avengers disassembled event
which is of course a series you can
watch here on my youtube channel but
this is done when some variation perhaps
even the real Jack of Hearts appears
after being I guess controlled by the
Scarlet Witch and blows up the Avengers
mansion and Scott Lang along with it and
so what we see here is that Scott Lang
is gone for a little while but what
happens is that Scott Lang reappears
Scott Lang comes back to the landscape
of Marvel Comics during the Children's
Crusade during the Avengers branch off
and what happens here is that his
daughter Cassandra Lang is taken into
the past
along with Scarlet Witch and a couple
other characters and while the initial
idea here is that their cap oriole form
cannot interact with physical people in
this time Cassandra Lang somehow manages
to break this barrier and she physically
encounters
her father and when she does Scott Lang
leaves the scene and he's not killed by
Jack of Hearts thereby allowing him to
remain in existence in in the main
earth-616 timeline now this is something
that's been heavily contested by a lot
of Marvel fans and the reason why is
because Marvel's been on again and off
again about branch universe theory for
the most part it's religious based on
the writers there are some instances
where the actions of some individuals
will create an alternate universe that
action being of course the assassination
of Charles Xavier which led to the Days
of Future past han line but in this
instance the fact that a Scott Lang had
gues encountered his daughter who in
turn led him away from the Avengers
mansion shortly before Jack of Hearts
blew up did not create a parallel
reality instead it allowed the
mainstream reality to follow suit and
for Scott Lang to stay alive but for the
most part Scott Lang has been a
relatively popular character in the
realm of Marvel Comics he's been a
character that in a lot of different
ways has been someone that a lot of fans
can identify with both both on a
personal level in terms of his physical
struggle but also the idea of a
character who had fallen from grace and
who had found Redemption with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]